then on the mound dylan bundy it's his
seventh start of the year
it's getting on base quite a bit more of
late starting to turn things north
outside corner that's strike three he
throws him with the breaking ball yeah
fastball inside corner at the knees that
was a strike this one is a borderline
breaking ball here from
fundy another punch out with a breaking
ball
hershawn his career has had a lot of
success against the angels
13 career starts seven and two 7-2 2.45
era and he has not suffered a loss in
his last
eight starts against the angels he has
not had a loss against the angels
going back to august of 2014.
in his 40th game against the dodgers
mike trout goes to work
another 2-2 kershaw gets it looking
the best facing the best on the mound
and the batter's box and sometimes you
know what mother nature the sun
gets in the way and my child made it
very clear he just did not pick up the
baseball very well though just one base
runner in this game combined
came on an air ward rojas and suzuki
coming up
payoff strikes him out good slider from
kershaw
75 of his strikeouts this year have come
on that pitch
one away for rojas back to back kaze to
open the third
curveball topped along third as all cal
state fullerton teammate justin turner
with a nice play
and a good play in the back end by
muncie as well corey seeger bounced to
second base in his first outback
it is a change and it's grounded through
the middle into center field for a base
hit
dodgers have them cornered with nobody
out and they have their first hit of the
game
one away here's muncie check swing
roller
foul
[Applause]
what a beginning of a relationship
beginning and end oh
everybody gets the smile but mookie okay
he does
one and two here it comes once he looks
a line drive to right center base head
that brings home bets who can take his
time getting there
seeger goes to third on an rbi single
from max muncie and the dodgers break
through first
up comes will smith smith goes out and
pokes it into right field to bring home
seeger back-to-back rbi hits from muncie
and smith and it's two nothing
bases loaded for baity 3-2 he yanks it
deep to right
back towards the wall and it won hops
the wall
muncie into score easily will smith's
head at home
it's a two-run double for matt beatty
and a fourth spot for the dodgers here
in the fourth
they've put lux on intentionally to load
them up for austin barnes
cube to the right side flexor can't get
it and
everybody's safe they lead
five nothing as taylor scores on the
second fletcher air tonight
and for the second time in this inning
mookie betts comes to the plate
started the anyway seems like forever
ago with a walk
somehow gets his bet on it and cues it
into right field for a base hit to bring
home two more
babies both in to score and everything
breaking the dodgers way here in the
fourth
biggest ending of the season for the
dodgers a seven run
fourth first one from sea shack
he's swinging tapper left side oh my
goodness
it's like three weeks where the luck is
coming their way
second and third two gone back to the
top and mookie bets
bangs it to right base it to drive home
two more
he's got four rbis tonight and they've
got double digits here in the fifth
that is over the glove of gasoline and
down the line to left to bring home
bounce
sager to third turn into second with an
rbi double
everybody's reached base they continue
to add on 11
nothing crackman right center field and
the hits just
keep on coming will smith drops this one
in
and drives in two more john jay gets the
call now
knocked down dennis ops off the bump
goes into a slide has a kick away
and an rbi walsh on the ground
base hit a couple of angels will score
13-3 again 13-3 and no question this is
a mount everest mountain that you have
got to climb
high fly ball left field play made out
there
come on down run scores in the form of
legaures it's 13 to four here's juan
lagarus batting runners at first and
second
agarra shoots it down the right field
line that
will hunt the corner that one will
played one they'll stop
jay hill hustle home while it's lobbed
into second he'll slide in safely
that's a hustle run for the angels you
like to see that you're fighting all the
way to the end
get a chance to watch jared walsh hit
again
rolled into the hole and right center
field you've got another run
closer it's 14-7 the beat goes on
ward fights it off tries to dump it into
center field and he does so
it's a 14-8 game it was 13 to nothing
it's now 14-8 and the dodgers are having
to get some of the top shelf stuff out
as far as relievers are concerned
runners on first
and third two outs an opportunity for
rojas
high fly ball deep right field jose
rojas
it's getting interesting
first career home run in the show
all of a sudden it's 14-11.
now you've got yourself a ball game no
team as ever
ever come from down 13 to nothing the
angels are now down to their final
out in this game trying to fire z02
bounce back to him that will do
what it wacky ride it was again they led
13-nothing
they hold on to win 14-11